Такого активного дипломатичного початку року ще не було. Через загрозу вторгнення Росії
Україну відвідують держсекретар США Ентоні Блінкен,
міністерка закордонних справ Німеччини Анналена Бербок, глава ЦРУ Вільям Бернс,
не кажучи вже про численних експертів і дипломатів нижчого рівня. І все це за лічені дні.
Цим візитам передував марафон переговорів у трьох форматах:
США-Росія у Женеві, НАТО-Росія у Брюсселі та ОБСЄ-Росія у Відні.
Гостроти ситуації додає той факт, що поки російські дипломати вели у Європі
переговори щодо зниження напруженості, у самій Росії повним ходом
йшли перекидання військ із Сибіру до західної частини Росії - ближче до українського кордону.
Такі кадри оприлюднюють журналісти-розслідувачі. Крім того, до Білорусі
почали прибувати російські війська для спільних навчань "Союзна рішучість-2022".
Військові маневри мають відбутися з 10 по 20 лютого.
Що це - фінальна підготовка до вторгнення чи гра м'язами для більшої ваги
під час переговорів із Заходом?
Російське керівництво використовує військовий інструмент, щоб змусити США,
насамперед США, але також і НАТО, говорити з ними, бо всі інші засоби не дали результатів.
У Росії, як ми знаємо, не найвагоміша економіка. І зовсім мало того,
що називається "soft power". Тому єдиний інструмент, який вони мають,
щоб союзники не розбіглися - це військова сила.
Відчутних результатів для деескалації переговорний марафон наразі, схоже, не приніс.
Позиції сторін непримиренні. Росії потрібні - цитата - "залізобетонні гарантії" того,
що Україна ніколи не стане членом НАТО. А для США, як, звісно, і для України,
це абсолютно неприйнятно. Позиція Заходу не змінилася: кожна країна має сама вирішувати
- вступати в НАТО чи ні, не запитуючи дозволу в Росії. США наголошують:
від Росії, якщо та хоче продовження розмови, потрібна деескалація.
Останні кілька місяців ми активно зосереджували увагу на Україні
через значне нарощування російських сил поблизу українського кордону.
Ми знаємо, що є плани ще збільшити ці сили за дуже короткий термін.
І це дає президенту Путіну можливість, також у дуже короткий термін,
вжити подальших агресивних дій проти України.
Тож невже ескалації конфлікту на українських кордонах не уникнути?
Ймовірно, російське військове керівництво могло б окупувати Україну.
Але політично це було б абсолютно безглуздо, бо управляти 44 мільйонами українців,
забезпечувати їх, тримати під контролем… Я не думаю, що це має сенс для Росії.
Вони зазнають у цьому крах, у них занадто багато проблем у своїй власній країні.
Тому це може бути лише наступ у районі Донбасу чи у районі Криму
з обмеженими цілями. Я б усе-таки не виключав такої можливості.
Андраш Раш з Німецького товариства зовнішньої політики вважає,
що Росія час для тиску на Захід та висування своїх вимог обрала невипадково.
У Німеччині новий уряд, але він ще далеко не зовсім працює на повну міць.
У ЄС головує Франція, а вона в свою чергу одночасно готується
до президентських виборів у себе вдома.
США й адміністрація Байдена потерпають від внутрішніх проблем,
а також наслідків катастрофічного виведення військ з Афганістану.
Крім того, за словами експертів, до президентських виборів у Росії ще два роки,
а цей час може знадобитися для згладжування економічних наслідків санкцій
у разі ескалації конфлікту. А ще в зимовий період мерзла земля,
що зручно для маневрів, необхідних для перекидання техніки.
На думку аналітиків, можливості діалогу дипломатичними каналами
нині вже майже вичерпані. Не став винятком і перший візит нової очільниці МЗС Німеччини
Анналени Бербок до Києва та Москви.
Будь-яка нова агресія, як ми неодноразово наголошували, матиме високу ціну.
Ми готові до серйозного діалогу із Росією. Тому що дипломатія
- єдиний дієвий спосіб розрядити нинішню вкрай небезпечну ситуацію.
Окрім слів підтримки на адресу України, суттєвого впливу на ситуацію
Німеччина наразі не має, схильні вважати німецькі експерти.
Російська сторона ясно дала зрозуміти, що хоче говорити виключно
з американцями про Україну та Донбас і що не вважає Нормандський формат
все ще актуальним. Щодо цього я не думаю, що з боку Москви
можна чекати якихось компромісів. А Київ вимагає постачання зброї від Німеччини.
Тож тут ми спостерігаємо швидше конфронтацію.
Напередодні візиту Бербок до Києва посол України у Берліні Андрій Мельник заявив,
що небажання допомагати Україні постачанням зброї "розчаровує"
та вчергове закликав Берлін переглянути свою позицію.
Міністр закордонних справ України Дмитро Кулеба сказав, що також порушував цю тему.
Проте Анналена Бербок повторила, що з приводу цього питання
позиція уряду ФРН залишається незмінною. Натомість вона запропонувала
допомогу німецьких фахівців для того, щоб розслідувати масштабну кібератаку
на урядові сайти України. Київ підозрює в їхній організації білоруських хакерів та Москву.
Ще одна з тем переговорів за участі Анналени Бербок у Києві та Москві
- трубопровід "Північний потік-2". Соціал-демократи, партнери "Зелених"
в урядовій коаліції ФРН, вважають за краще не змішувати питання
про запуск труби з політикою. Однак у разі нападу РФ на Україну
Німеччина готова обговорити з партнерами і можливість відмови
від "Північного потоку-2", визнав канцлер ФРН Олаф Шольц.
На думку аналітиків, Європа перестала відігравати значну роль
у вирішенні російсько-українського конфлікту. Передусім у Берліна зараз
не дуже гарний імідж в очах українців. І Німеччина, за словами експертів,
сама частково винна в тому, що перестала відігравати провідну роль.
Коли ми бачимо, що каже частина соціал-демократів і як обережно діють "зелені",
то мені не здається це адекватною відповіддю на те, що Москва
зараз робить у сусідніх країнах. Щодо цього ми стаємо менш значущими.
Німеччина більше не є лідером у ЄС із цих питань.
І мені здається це якоюсь втратою зв'язку з реальністю.
Німецькі експерти закликали новий уряд ФРН докорінно змінити політику щодо Росії.
Понад 70 фахівців з питань Східної Європи та політики безпеки
оприлюднили відкритий лист. Автори звернення наголосили,
що подальша "не більше ніж словесна чи символічна реакція Берліна
на "російські ревізіоністські авантюри" лише спонукає Кремль до "нових ескапад".
На тлі поки, здавалося б, безуспішного дипломатичного марафону,
позитивними є сигнали про конкретну допомогу Україні окремих країн Заходу.
З Великобританії до України вже прибули легкі протитанкові оборонні системи.
Канада не лише розглядає питання надання зброї ЗСУ, а й направила в Україну
невеликий контингент елітних спецпризначенців.
Уряд Данії виділяє понад 22 мільйони євро, зокрема на підвищення
обороноздатності України. А Пентагон вже повідомив, що надати
додаткову підтримку ЗСУ для посилення оборонних можливостей готові США.